[Music]
[Music]
so i thought i would quickly go over
some ways that i simplify and break down
dense chords
so this isn't a formal approach that's
tied to music theory but rather
something that combines music theory and
also the layout of the keys and other
pianistic elements so going back to this
chord
i look at it as a first inversion d flat
major chord
plus
a perfect fifth
[Music]
another way to look at the left hand is
all black keys
and then the second block he lowered
and then in the right hand stacked
perfect fifths
so as you can see this is really a
pianistic way of looking at it
and it's not really taking into
consideration the scales or harmonic
devices that messian was using
to create this chord
go to this chord
[Music]
this one is pretty simple i would look
at it as
a first inversion a major chord plus a
first inversion g major chord
[Music]
this measure is really about the melody
over these chords
so the first thing that pops out to me
is that the a flat and the e flat
are repeated
and then the rest of it's very simple
because they're minor thirds
that are basically going down
chromatically
and then back up
and then back down
there's one last thing which is this
middle voice in the left hand starting
from the e flat
so that's basically it i i hope to talk
more about different ways that i look at
chords and and patterns in the future
but this is all for now
thanks for watching